bet you didn't know this and we'll kick
it off with this napoleon you heard
napoleon right
for those that haven't heard of napoleon
tell us who he
who he was and you actually said that he
accepted islam
correct the french conqueror
we all know about him we all studied
about him but we were never told that
toward the end of his life in the exile
he was he he converted to islam
and actually some of those who were his
companions close to him in the exile
they testified that he used to pray and
he used to read quran
now this is academically sound yes i
mean you're an academic
that's in his in his own biography this
is not from a muslim or
uh people can go verify some google
website
that napoleon
accepted islam correct this is deep
correct
in his own biography in his own
biography now
what are some of the top uh just to
mention please napoleon conquered egypt
and he claimed to convert at that time
and that was
and he wore the thobe and yeah he wore
the the turban
but that all was propaganda just to to
touch on the
emotions of the muslims to pass his own
agenda but later on
in the exile toward the end of his life
he converted for real
he was french yeah french now now this
is a coming from a place i mean he's
actually like a hero to many friends
right oh yeah big time
but but you see a lot of uh oppression
towards muslims
even though the french i don't think
they would have won the last soccer
match the world champion if it wasn't
for many of the muslims out of there
right
but you see them was it banning hijab
and minarets and all other things over
there french is the heart of
christianity
french orders throughout the history
represents the heart of christianity
so if if i mean french is under the
threat of
turning into muslims because of the
refugees because of the immigrations
because of that
that's why there and there's a lot of
racism
in the french over the history you can
you can test for it
a lot of uh orientalists you know came
from there
orientalists were the people after the
the failure of the crusades
in the muslim world to convert muslims
into leaving islam at least and then
christianity they failed to do that so
they said the best way then we need to
study this peel
so they start sending orientalists
called mustache recline
who who posed as muslims and they
learned everything about muslims they
learned everything these people went
into the marketplaces in the masajid and
the circles of knowledge
they learned everything about muslims
and they went back to europe and they
started documenting that and giving
recommendation
how we can conquer these people wow and
the
the things that happening in the muslim
world over the last hundred years
is is the fruit of all these three of
all this research
because they realize these muslims are
different than us christians
it's not easy to to uproot them from
their religion so how we gonna do
that's why they you hear a lot of
sayings for example
give me give me a prostitute and a glass
of wine
and i can do to the umm of muhammad more
than cannons
and armies did you hear that
fallen desire give me a woman give me a
glass of wine alcohol
and uh using exploiting the woman now
right
and you and you advocate like you know
the uh rights of women but you're
actually subjugating her
in this way denigrating her yeah but
then you can destroy
more than what cannons and armies can do
wow
they know them those are those uh
satanic traps
desires then yeah this is where the
ummafil islam is
our deen is the right deen our quran is
the perfect book
our prophet is the best messenger so how
can they attack us through them
they can't so they said we have to get
to them through the shahawat and the
desires
and we're humans and we're weak you know
do you find it ironic that you see that
everyone is trying to make islam as if
as if it's oppressive towards humanity
it's backwards
but then when you look at it you study
islam you know you go back in history
you know when the muslims were the
superpowers you know the christians jews
and everyone
what kind of rights did they have living
under the superpower at that time
compared to now
where muslims are like losing most of
their rights
like under the muslim superb being i
tell you what
a hebrew professor and he a jewish
professor in hebrew
jewish hebrew professor jewish professor
in a
hebrew university in jerusalem
and he writes he said that there was
never bearish imbues
between muslims and jews than under
islamic andalus
islamic spain and if you look if you
read
the little history or some of the
history of spain
that's where the jews were mistreated
they were scholars
they were given the opportunity to be
merchants business people scholars
philosophers under islamic ruling you
know
so when you're when you're objective you
have to testify in the favor of this
deen
and this is by again by a jewish
occupant
you know i mean the jews the israelis
and palestine and palestine are
occupation
so he's praising muslims right saying
that the jews never had better
environment
to excel than in muslim spain when
muslims were ruling spain
then the the the christians come the
catholic comes to spain
what they do to the jews and to the
muslims they slaughter them or if you
don't if you don't convert we kill you
if you don't want to be killed you leave
and if you look later on in in germany
who helped the jews from uh hitler and
the nazis
the ottomans the ottomans send their
ships to save a lot of the jews from
from germany so this is what islam this
is what islam came
where was when they talk about women
what was the status of women when
muhammad saw
them came to talk about what was in the
dark ages in europe
what was a woman they were arguing in
the church if a woman
comes from satan or not if a woman worth
half a man or not if she has a soul
that's another thing you know a woman
here in this country when did they start
voting
you know isla so you say there is
development right there's progressive
great but islam started with progression
started with it
from the get-go from the beginning wow
yeah
yeah america took how many years to get
to a point where a woman is
we're still talking about women wages
right not equal to man wages in america
right yeah
so still in in the form of evolution
islam from the beginning
you